i love talking about the weird [ __ ]
that's happened to me on stage
yo this is far and away my favorite
weird [ __ ] story i talk about it a lot
so it seems to follow me to my shows
and uh
a couple weeks ago maybe a couple months
now in dallas i was on stage and there
was a dude sitting right where you are
and he was wearing a kilt
and so if you're going to wear a kilt in
the front row i'm going to ask you about
it right
so i go i go what's with the kilt
and he said i wrestle
i wrestle in west texas on a little
circuit and he had red hair and a red
beard and he was like i do the whole
irish thing i go that's cool
and we were talking real gregarious dude
i like guys like that good storyteller
and
so i said to him i go oh so you're
wearing the kilt you must have wrestled
today and he goes no
i said so what's with the kilt and he
just started doing this
and he goes it gets sticky here in
dallas and i was like
all right
didn't need that visual but i got you i
got you now
this doing this by telling me it gets
sticky
look i had to ask him the question i go
are you wearing
you wearing underwear
and he goes i'm going to tell you what i
tell everybody else
you go lift it up to find out
and i said i'm telling you something
you're challenging the wrong guy
[Applause]
yo you telling me i can lift up that
kilt and see a human dick and make this
whole room uncomfortable i'm on board
for that [ __ ]
yo that's my wheelhouse guys i grew up
with three older brothers i like making
people uncomfortable
i think human dick at a show is going to
make people uncomfortable right
and so he says to me he goes i've asked
about a million people to lift a kilt
and nobody's ever said they would do it
and i was like well
you're going to learn today
and he goes just like this
spreads his legs like this and he goes
get in there
he was trying to alpha me like he was
trying to make me uncomfortable i can't
have you out for me at my show so how
can i make you more uncomfortable than
you're trying to make me as soon as he
said get in there i just dropped to my
knees just like this
and
he went like this
and he said do you do you have to do
that from your knees
and i was like
yeah yeah
i said in my experience is the best view
of a dick
he goes he goes all right and then he
said he goes but if you're going to do
this
you got to keep eye contact with me i'm
like this dude's [ __ ] me up
yo every time i tried to alpha me he
came right on top
and i was like well i'm not gonna let
him make me uncomfortable i said fine so
he and i just started staring at each
other
and i reached for this dude's kilt now i
got to tell you on the outside on the
outside i was cool as a cucumber guys
on the inside
yo you know when you're
you know when you're so nervous it's
like your asshole's gasping for breath
you know
your butthole's like get us out of here
what the [ __ ] are we doing here get it
what are we doing
i reach down
and i just
now does anybody have any kilt knowledge
in here
are you left here you know what i didn't
know about the kill two sides of the
kill yeah one side when you lift it up
there's just more kill
that's the side i lifted up first
so i lift it up and he goes just like
this he leaps he
leans back and he goes whoopsie
[Music]
and he said i bury the treasure on the
other side
and i just
human dick yeah real dick yeah
and it was a redheaded situation i'd
never seen one of those before
yo it was so much brighter than i
thought it was gonna be
i'm not gonna lie to you it looked
irritated
it looked like someone ran up to it and
just went
and yo this dude was all potatoes no
meat you know
for real his dick looked like he fell
asleep on his nuts just
his dick looked like it blew a bubble
just
24 damn living liquor just to make it
through another 24.
smoking i'm getting high just to balance
out the lows and they always tell me
that i should be living
but you know how the story goes
another day another dollar howler 7 pm
once again i'm breaking up the bugs